[Musique]
c'est l'étoile la plus près de nous et
le nouveau grand sujet d'étude de la
nasa qui compte sur parker sur leur prob
une sonde hors du commun pour percer
plusieurs de ses mystères sont des fils
approchées tout près du soleil sans se
transformer instantanément en poussière
des toiles c'est une somme très complexe
parce que elle doit à la fois se
protéger de la chaleur du émise par le
soleil et en même temps transmettre ces
données le secret de la sonde qui a la
taille d'une automobile c'est son
bouclier thermique extrêmement léger et
résistant qui fait de noyaux de mousse
de carbone prise en sandwich entre deux
plaques de composites de carbone
le bouclier pu supporter des
températures de 1400 degrés celsius
similaire à celle de la lave en fusion
derrière lui les instruments
scientifiques sont protégés par un
système de refroidissement qui les
maintient à 30 degrés en tout temps eu
des principaux objectifs comprendre la
dynamique de la très étrange couronne
solaire
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que le soleil
à une température de surface d'environ
6000 degrés celsius et que la couronne
solaire donc la partie et après la
surface du soleil atteint des
températures d'environ 1.5 millions de
degrés et on ne connaît pas les
processus encore bien qui permettent de
passer de 6 mille degrés à 1.5 millions
de degrés
la sonde étudiera également les
éruptions solaires et les vents solaires
ces phénomènes qui menacent parfois les
systèmes de télécommunications sur terre
durant sa mission de sept ans la sonde
s'approchera plusieurs reprises à moins
de 4 millions de km du soleil
du jamais vu ce qui est un peu stressant
pour toute l'équipe qui sera en place
c'est que pendant le moment où la sonde
passe près très près du soleil à environ
pendant une dizaine de jours en fait on
va perdre le contact avec la sonde
on n'aura aucun moyen de communiquer
avec elle et ça c'est vraiment stressant
surtout avec un engin qui coûte 1.5
milliards de dollars mise en orbite par
un puissant lanceur delta faut rêver la
sonde se déplacera à la vitesse
ahurissante de 700 mille kilomètres à
l'heure
l'équivalent du voyage montréal québec
un que plus d'une seconde
ici normand grondin radio canada
montréal